hello my name is andrew you might
recognize me from the show worth it
where i'm usually tasting
foods at different price points with my
pals steven and adam in this video i'm
going to be making one of my favorite
things
i ever had on worth it soy milk not just
any soy milk but the freshly made soy
milk we had at lu jiao shuijinbao
in our dumpling episode in taiwan having
that soy milk was a
real holy crap moment for me
i didn't know that's what soy milk's
supposed to taste like i never tasted
freshly made soy milk before my previous
experience was just having the
store-bought stuff
after having that soy milk i felt like
such an idiot because i thought i knew
what soy milk tasted like but
then i had this and i was like yeah of
course there's great
delicious rich tasting soy milk i think
making this recipe will help me
explore something that i'm really
interested in which is the fundamentals
of why
something tastes good holy sh soy milk
is one of those food things that
seems very simple and singular kind of
like
butter but it has this incredible
potential for flavor
that is actually very nuanced and
complex so to start off i'm gonna be
speaking with miss lou
and inka who is also on that trip with
us it's so nice to see you again
long time no see andrew yeah and inca
thank you as well for
joining me on this call inca i want to
start by asking you a question
i remember when we were filming at miss
lose you were so excited i think how's
the soy milk
like almost done oh my goodness i really
like the soy milk this is really good
and i was wondering if you could just
talk
about your experience with what you
might find in taiwan soy milk i feel
like in taiwan
especially it's just like such a common
drink you know it's like something that
you enjoy by itself
and also there's so much you can do with
soy milk tofu tofu pudding dried bean
curd one of our most famous desserts
tofu pudding is made with soy milk
how would you describe the flavor of
great soy milk
[Music]
coffee
[Music]
your shop has a relatively small menu i
was wondering why it's also important
for you to offer this freshly made soy
milk
at this shop as well
for sharing with me and and talking to
me yeah yeah
all right so we've got our ingredients
which it turns out is just
soybean water and then a little sugar to
sweeten it when it's done
which makes me scared because my
experience every time
i've had to make a recipe where the
ingredient list is very short
it usually goes horribly wrong i also
have to thank miss liu she actually
adapted
the recipe that they use in her
restaurant to
a home version and tested that for me
oh god
i mean is it stupid to say that it just
smells like a bean like a green bean
ah 500 grams of soy beans
our first step is to wash and
soak these for six hours so here we have
our soaked soybeans what's interesting
is that they they go from being
balls to being more of a traditional
bean
shape it just occurred to me that i have
no idea what a soybean
plant looks like
yeah it looks like a lot of other beans
and i've had edamame before of course
so i'm going to strain this water off
put this back in the pot here i'm now
adding
six cups of water and then we are going
to
blend these soybeans this is the part
that might go wrong for me miss lou had
a nice high-powered blender i'm using my
stick blender again so
also i haven't tasted a soybean because
i was doing some other research uh it
could
really upset your stomach possibly hurt
you eating the uncooked soybean but you
know what i just noticed
these soybeans look like a pot of yukon
gold potatoes
we get a shot of that real quick it's
crazy how much a single soybean looks
like a potato
just kidding that was a potato but look
at these soybeans doesn't it look like a
pot of potatoes from really far away
come on come on that was good right nice
potato trick
miss liu does this for several minutes
so i think i really need to get
like a fine fine grain paste
inside of here
[Music]
it already smells really good in its
blended state
it has like a delightful like enticing
frothiness to it
here we have our soy milk ground up
slurry
so miss lou has these filter bags
that she pours all of her ground up soy
into i was only able to find cheesecloth
but i saw other recipes using
cheesecloth
so it should be fine it also feels
appropriate to use cheesecloth because
this method
is very similar to the method that's
used to make tofu
i believe the only difference is that
you'd use a coagulating agent
and making tofu is therefore a lot like
making cheese
okay oh it's actually
really not pouring through as quickly as
i thought it would oh
i over filled my satchel here a little
bit trying really hard to get all this
stuff out it's such a dense blob right
now there's a lot more
water to extract from here but you
really gotta squeeze hard
now going to take these ground soybeans
drop them into a side bowl the color is
actually very pretty it's very
buttery so that was a third of the
soybeans i'm gonna try to do a little
less i think i'll have an easier
time squeezing out so now that we've
done the first squeeze
miss lou suggests adding another three
cups of water
to the ground soybean to extract even
more liquid from this ground soybean
ah give this a quick stir
i don't know if it's just this sunset
lighting over here but i'm finding this
incredibly relaxing experience
something about cheesecloth that just
kind of conveys a
rustic cooking process kind of vibe
coarse materials are very cozy
okay we've strained our soy milk and now
it's time to boil
welcome to the stove area so i've
cleaned the second pot
and the next step is actually to
transfer all the squeezed soy milk
liquid
into the second pot and then i have a
residue
in the first pot that's supposed to
brown a little bit
not burn but just brown and then that
flavor
will impart into the rest of the soy
milk most of the liquid has evaporated
i'm starting to see a little browning i
really don't want to
burn this yeah it's getting kind of like
a
toasted popcorn smell to it i'm pouring
it now
okay i'm actually supposed to use a
whisk i'm gonna turn this down a little
bit
because i feel the soy milk that charred
on the bottom
is still there i see that there's some
kind of like
toasted solids that are now kind of
floating around
they're also on my whisk i don't think
that's too big of a concern because
we're actually going to
put this through the cheesecloth again
after it boils
oh my god very nearly had a disaster on
my hands
okay the soy milk is boiled pour the
milk back through
my cheesecloth so this seems to have
taken out most of the charred bits and
now
it's going to return this to a boil
[Music]
okay the soy milk is now boiling last
ingredient
is just a little bit of sugar to sweeten
the deal soy milk is often enjoyed
hot but i want to have it as close to
the experience that i had at miss lou's
back in taiwan
which was cool i'll chill it in the
refrigerator overnight
and tomorrow we may taste
i made a lot of soy milk this is
uh especially in this jar i kind of feel
like
a milkman all right so i think there's
not much else to do but to uh
you know there's a lot of condensation
happening here
i think it's just time to have some soy
milk there's something very pleasing
about a glass of milk okay
[Music]
cheers
wow tastes really good
hold on let me let's uh
[Music]
it's very good i think i'm very pleased
and uh
relieved that i didn't um royally screw
this up but it was a very simple method
it has a very pleasant thickness to it
it really tastes like a full fat product
so out of curiosity i actually bought
some
store-bought soy milk to do a
side-by-side
way less fragrant than the store-bought
one
the the visual viscosity between these
seems to be the same you know they seem
equally liquidy
yet this one tastes so much thinner
than mine all right so there's my soy
milk i had a lot of fun making this
thank you again so much to ms liu for
guiding me through this process
it kind of changes your whole
perspective on what
a thing is all foods have a similar
potential
but too often we confine them to one
category or use
i think it's very interesting